تجهز اوكرانيا منذ شهور بهجومها المضاد
الذي تعول عليه لاستعاده مناطق تحت
السيطره الروسيه في الجبهات الشرقيه
والغربيه
وسعت من نطاق ضرباتها بقصف صاروخي طويل
المدى اصاب اهدافا روسيه بعيده عن الخطوط
الاماميه ثم تحركت فرق صغيره نسبيا من
الوحدات الاوكرانيه المدرعه عبر الحقول
المفتوحه باتجاه جنوب شرق زقروشيا في
محاوله جاده لاستطلاع الدفاعات الروسيه
عند نقاط عده على طول خط التماس فما
السيناريوهات المحتمله للهجوم المضاد
تتوزع العمليات القتاليه على عده محاور في
محاوله لتوسيع رقعه استجابه الجيش الروسي
شرقيه
تشهد الجبهه الممتده على طول قرابه 15
كيلومترا اشتباكات مستمره في اي خاف جنوب
شرق سابولوجيا ايضا دفعت كييف ارتالا من
الدبابات والمدرعات ونقلات الجند الى
منطقه ممتده لنحو 12 كيلومترا في محاولات
لاقتحام الدفاعات الروسيه في محيط بخموت
تحاول القوات المهاجمه اختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه في اتجاه كرسنالورا شماليه ضخمه
جنوبا
شمالا حركه النشيطه للقوات الاوكرانيه في
شرقي كوبيانسك
بالتزامن تنشط العمليات شماليه مكيفكا مع
محاولات اختراق في مناطق جنوب افديافكا
وفي اقصى الشرق تستمر المعارك في ذلك
اللتين تشكلان نقطتين مهمتين ستحاول
اوكرانيا عبرهما اختراق الخطوط الروسيه
تهدف القوات الاوكرانيه اضافه لتشتيت
انتباه الجيش الروسي الى احداث ثغره
واختراق يفصل بين الجبهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه في اقليم دومباس عند ميلتوبول
وماريوبول وسبولوجيا ما يمهد لاحقا في حال
نجاح الهجوم للوصول لشواطئ بحر ازوف
وتهديد البحريه الروسيه في قواعد شبه
جزيره القرم هذا بدوره قد يستتبع اضطرابا
في خطوط امداد القوات الروسيه هذا
السيناريو المحتمل للهجوم الاوكراني بدا
يشهد بعض العراقيل
ابرزها تفجير سدك خوفكا الذي يقدر خبراء
انه سيؤخر اي هجوم اوكراني محتمل في هذا
الاتجاه وهو ادى بالفعل الى تراجع القوات
الروسيه عن اماكن تموضعها يضاف الى ذلك
الخسائر التي تتعرض لها القوات الهاشمه
نتيجه وجود دفاعات روسيه محكمه في نقاط
واسعه قائمه منذ السيطرتها على هذه
المناطق وانخفاض قدره سلاح الجو الاوكراني
على تامين غطاء للقوات المهاجمه
[موسيقى]